In this video, and the future videos that we'll be going through, we are going to be jumping into the engine.
So, to follow along, it would be good if you can open and create an Unreal project.
For this workshop, I will be using the First Person Shooter template.
So, in order to do that, if you can open your Epic Installer, and go to the Unreal Engine tab,
select the Library tab, and hopefully by this point you have an engine version installed.
If not, just click on this plus button and install it.
But, I am going to launch 5.31.
It will take a minute to fire up.
Once the engine has fired up, come and select the Games tab, and under the Games tab,
we will have the First Person template.
Now, one more thing that I would like you to do is if you could tick the button for Start Content,
what this is going to do is it's going to include some basic meshes and materials
that we can use in the example we're going to be making.
Choose a project location and then a project name, and then just hit the Create.
Once the project has loaded up, you should see a screen which looks something like this.
Now, I'm going to do one extra thing here.
I am going to select the Content Draw, and I'm going to dock it into the layout.
The reason being, we're going to be working with assets in the Content Draw quite a lot,
so it'll be useful to have this visible at all times.
Now we have the project started up.
It'll be good for us to have a blueprint that we can play around with and explain.
So, to do that, I am going to right-hand click within the content directory,
and I'm going to get a menu of content that I can create.
I'm going to select Blueprint Class.
This will bring up a box which is going to show us all of the different parent classes
which we could possibly create a child class of.
Now, to start with, you can see that we have the Actor, Horn, and Character classes.
These are the three classes which we mentioned previously in the examples.
The Actor, the Character being a child of the Pawn class,
and the Pawn class being a child of the Actor class.
We also have the Player Controller.
This is not a child of the Actor and cannot be seen within the world,
but it can take control of the Pawn.
And we have a few other classes of interest down here.
Actor component being interesting because in the Character component,
the Skeletal Mesh and the Movement are both Actor components which are just attached to this
class. If at any point you want to create a child which is not on this list, down below
we have a drop-down box which will give us access to all of the different classes that
are available to us. Now, this can be augmented by either adding plugins
or by creating and adding extra classes to the system.
But what is useful as well is you can actually see the hierarchy here.
So, for example, you can see that we have under the Object class, we have the Actor class,
the Actor component, there are numerous other ones.
But if I was to do a drop-down of the Actor class, we can see that there are a whole
load of other Actors that are objects that we can be dragged into the world.
Now, for this example, we are going to use a simple Actor class,
and this is a common starting point for creating Blueprints.
In this, I'm going to rename this to be just Example,
and then I'm going to double-click on it to open it up.
And with that, we should be ready to start doing some coding.